خطر الحرب الكبرى يعود من جديد نعم يا
ساده مقاتله امريكيه تسقط في الاجواء
الروسيه والعالم يحبس انفاسه بخموت تشتعل
والخريف يحل على البنوك الامريكيه والازمه
الاقتصاديه تشخص اعينها نحو العالم باسره
والخساره تبدا بدوله خليجيه انه كلب ميت
والاخر سيشعل الحرب العالميه فمن يقصد
الرجل الاصفر احتفال نووي غربي لمواجهه
الصين وبيكين ترد مدينه العطور تتحول الى
مكب نفايات ومصر تثير رعب الكيان
الاسرائيلي وصفقه سعوديه تعيد الحياه
للاقتصاد الامريكي
الحرب العالميه تقترب حرب يدفع العالم
برمته كي لا تندلع حرب لن تبقي ولن تذر
حرب سيكون طرفيها هم اصحاب اكثر من 11 الف
راس النووي اما ضحيتها فهي الكره الارضيه
بمن فيها وهنا اندلعت شرارتها حين اعلنت
قياده القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا اصطدام
مقاتله روسيه سبعه وعشرين بطائره امريكيه
بدون طيار امكيوناين خلال اعتراضها فوق
البحر الاسود مما ادى الى تحطم المسيره
الامريكيه لترد الدفاع الروسيه ان السقوط
المسيره الامري التي كانت متجهه نحو اجواء
القرن في البحر الاسود وتحطمها جاء بعد
فقدانها ارتفاعها وانا مقاتلتين روسيتين
اقلعتا الاعتراضها ولم تسقطها يبدو ان
طائره الامريكان سقطت خوفا من المواجهه
فهل تكون هذه المسيره الامريكيه سببا لحرب
ستجوب العالم من الحرب العالميه المحتمله
الى باغموت ام المعارك الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلن مؤسس قوات فاجنر الروسيه
تستعد لشن هجوم مضاد في مدينه ارتيموفيسك
بجمهوريه جونيتس على امل فك حصار القوات
الروسيه عنها هناك في باخموت او ما تسمى
حاليا حرب شوارع عنيفه في المناطق
الشماليه من المدينه وفق موقع ريبار
العسكري ليصف بريكوجينا الوضع
بانه صعب للغايات مضيفا ان الاوكرانيين
يتشبثون بكل متر في المدينه ويصلهم الدعم
دون توقف وبامدادات لا نهايه لها ولكن
التقدم يستمر بفضل قواته وبفضل السلاح
الروسي حسب قوله واصبح القتال الدائر منذ
شهور للسيطره على المدينه اكثر معارك قوات
المشاه الدمويه في اوروبا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ويصف كل جانب القتال على
بخموت بانه قتال ضارب ليخرج الرئيس
الاوكراني
واصفا لوضعف الجبهه الشرقيه بانه صعب جدا
ومؤلم جدا مضيفا انه يجب عليهم تدمير قوه
العسكريه للعدو وسوف يدمرونها فعلا وفق
قوله معلنا زياده الدعم المالي للجيش بنحو
13 مليار دولار صمود الاوكراني في بخموت
قد يستمر اكثر حيث اصبح الجيش الاوكراني
جاهزا للقتال بدبابات ليبرتو في ساحه
المعركه بعد اسابيع من التدريب المكثف في
المانيا وفق صحيفه زيت الالمانيه فيما
اختم عشرات الجنود تدريبات على
اسبانيا كذلك هناك تخطط
هجوم مضاد في وقت لاحق في الربيع عندما
تجف الاراضي الموحده وتصل مئات المركبات
المدرعه والدبابات الغربيه من طرازي
تشالنجر
وفق رويترز ومن حرب البارود الى حرب
الغذاء وبعد ان مددت موسكو اتفاق الحبوب
لمده 60 يوما اضافيا فقط ضرر نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه الكسان
لستيني يوما قائلا من روسيا تعتمد في
قراراتها لترى مدى فعاليه تنفيذ البنود
الخاصه في تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه
الروسيه وفق قناه ازديستيا تدهور الاقتصاد
الامريكي
الولايات المتحده في سباق مع عقارب الساعه
فبنوكها توشك على التهاوي كاحجار الدومينو
بعد ان افلس بنك سيليكون بالي لتعود
الانظار الى عام 2008 حين فشلت امريكا
بانقاذ بنكي الذي اعلن افلاسه مسببا ما
وصفاء بانه تسونامي الاقتصاد العالمي فهل
يتكرر المشهد بعد هبوط الاسهم الامريكيه
اليوم هنا يخرج بايدن مطمئنا المودعين بان
ودائعهم في امان وانا بامكانهم استردادها
حسب قوله لكن بيض لا يدري ان القيمه
السوقيه للشركات الماليه قد انخفضت في
جميع انحاء العالم في يومين من التداول
بمقدار
465 مليار
وذلك بعد افلاس سيلكون فالي وفقا لوكاله
بلومبرج لتسجل الاسهم المدرجه في بورصه
الكويت خسائر سوقيه بقيمه مليار
و247 مليون دينار كويتي اينما يعادل اربعه
مليارات دولار امريكي فهل يعيد بايدن ما
خسرته الكويت لننتقل هنا نحو الرجل
الامريكي الاصفر نعم انه دونالد ترامب
الذي وصف منافسه الجمهوري في السباق
الرئاسي بالكلب الميت بينما شن هجوما
لادعا على اداره
معها قد ينتهي الحال بنا بالحرب العالميه
الثالثه فبرايكم هل الحلول العالم اليوم
في يد الرجل الاصفر حقا حفله نوويه على
شرف مواجهه صينيه هنا اجتمعوا وهنا اقاموا
حفلتهم فعن اي حفله نتحدث فانه احتفال
نووي غربي في قاعده لوما البحريه وجهه
النحو الصين في اجتماع ثلاثي للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيسي الوزراء
البريطاني والاسترالي ليسرح بايدن نحن لا
نسعى لتهديد الصين هناك وضع المجتمعون
اللمسات الاخيره على اتفاق تزويد استراليا
بغواصات تقليديه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
ليعود بيض مؤكدا ان الغواصات تسير بالطاقه
النوويه وليست ذات اسلحه نوويه الرد
الصيني جاء على لسان الخارجيه صينيه في
بيان قالت فيه انه طريق خاطئ وخطر هذا
الذي تسلكه شراكه المبرمه بين الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا ضمن برنامج
الغواصات الهاتف الى مواجهه نفوذ بكين في
المحيط الهادئ وماذا بعد يا اصحاب العيون
الضيقه
ستردون على ارض الواقع اذا وهنا انضمت
روسيا للصين في ردها حيث اعتبر وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجينا ان اتفاق
الغواصات ضمن التحالف اوكس سيؤدي الى
مواجهات تستمر لسنوات في اسيا هنا القاره
الاسيويه في حيره من امرها يا اصدقاء فكيف
لها ان تمنع مواجهات هذه الهوامر العالميه
وبين هذا وذاك ظهرت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي كاثرينكس لتقول ان زياده موازنه
الدفاع تهدف لمواجهه التحدي الذي تطرحه
الصين والتهديد الروسي في اوروبا
الاحداث والتطورات في المانيا تعطل اكثر
من 100 الف مسافر نتيجه اضراب موظفي الامن
في ثلاثه مطارات عمال النظافه في باريس
يواصلون اضرابهم احتجاجا على رفع سن
التقاعد لت العاصمه الفرنسيه من مدينه
السحر والعطور والجمال الى مكب للنفايات
اصبح للقوات الجويه المصريه اول طائره تصل
الى عشره الاف ساعه طيران اي طائره رافال
المقاتله الفرنسيه وذلك يعد تفوقا لسلاح
الجو المصري
عملياتيا وتدريبا مع التحذير من تفقه
البالغ وهذا ما قاله التلفزيون الاسرائيلي
اعرب البيت الابيض عن سعادته من ان الشركه
بوينت تمكنت اخيرا من ابرام صفقات مع
السعوديه لبيع 121 طائره في حوالي 37
مليار دولار بعد سنوات من المناقشه
والمفاوضات المكثفه وصل رئيس النظام
السوري بشار الاسد الى موسكو في زياره
رسميه الى روسيا الاتحاديه تجري خلالها
محادثات مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوت ين
سقوط المسيره الامريكيه بالتزامن مع
السقوط الاسهم الامريكيه يؤججان قلق
الولايات المتحده ويزيدان من خطر مواجهات
عالميه في الفتره المقبله تعني الوضع كذلك
برايكم
[موسيقى]